Çeviri: Gözde Caymazer
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Emre Soyer
Davranış Bilimci
Bayanlar baylar.
Fırsat. Nasıl kaçar?
Yakalamak istiyorsak önce nasıl
kaçtığına bakmak lazım.
Kim bu çocuk?
Harry Potter.
Harry Potter’ı tanımayan var mı?
Duymadım diyen?
Görmedim kim bu?
Var mı? Yok. Dünyada da pek yok.
Dünyanın gelmiş geçmiş en
çok satan kitap serisi.
Gelmiş geçmiş. 73 tane lisana çevrilmiş.
Yazarı dünya çapında ünlü.
Filmleri var, kitapları var.
Ama geri gidelim, Harry Potter’ı hiç
kimsenin tanımadığı bir zamana.
1990'ların başına.
J.K Rowling yazarı,
Edinburg’da bir kafede yazıyor
bu kitabın çoğunu. İlkini.
Ben gittim o kafenin olduğu yere sonra.
Çaylar içtim, kahveler içtim.
Belki de hani suyundandır hani.
Yazıyor bitiriyor. Yayıncıya götürüyor.
Yayıncı bu işin uzmanı,
bundan para kazanacak.
Alıyor Harry Potter’a bakıyor, bundan
hiçbir şey olmaz diyor. İyi günler.
Fırsat kaçıyor.
Durun ikinciye götürüyor. Üzgünüz.
Üçüncüye götürüyor. Kalsın.
Dört. Beş. Altı. Yedi. Sekiz.
Dokuz. On. Onbir.
On iki kere reddediliyor Harry Potter.
On iki bu işin uzmanı ellerinin
tersiyle bu fırsatı itiyorlar.
On üçüncüsü ne yapacağını bilmiyor.
Evine gidiyor, masasının üzerine
koyuyor kitabı.
Küçük kızı geliyor, yanlışlıkla alıyor
‘biraz okuyor ‘baba baba’ diyor
bunun devamı var mı?’
Aa diyor kıyamam senin hatırına bin
tane basayım ben diyor adam.
Bin tanecik. Oradan efsane. Fenomen.
O on iki tane reddeden yayıncı her gün
sabah ilk saatleriyle kalkıyorlar evde,
kafayı vuruyorlar dan dan dan.
Çünkü fırsat kaçıyor.
Bu, bir şey değil.
Aynı anda, bununla aynı anda dünyanın
öbür ucunda iki tane doktora öğrencisi
Sergey Brin ve Larry Page bir
proje üzerinde çalışıyorlar.
Aynı anda bir tane de arama motoru icat
ediyorlar. Çok basit bir sayfa yapıyorlar.
Adına da Google diyorlar.
Google'ı tanımayan var mı? Ben görmedim
Google ne? Bu fırsatı kaçırmayın.
Google. Dünyada da yok tanımayan.
Herkes tanıyor.
Ülke gibi. 400 milyar dolar
değerinde bugün.
Dünyanın en başarılı
şirketlerinden bir tanesi.
Türkiye’nin gayri safi milli hasılası
800 milyar dolar. Ülke gibi.
Ama bu işin de başına gidelim.
Harry Potter reddedilirken
Google da diyor ki ben
bu fikri satacağım.
Daha başlamadan, patlamadan fikir.
Bakıyor kim var, kim ilgilenir.
O zamanlar etrafta mesela Altavista var.
Altavista’yı hatırlayan var mı?
Benim öğrencilerimin hiçbiri
hatırlamıyor. İyi günler Altavista.
Altavista ile akşam yemeği yiyorlar.
O zamanın bir numaralı arama motoru,
bu konunun uzmanı.
Oturuyorlar, Altavista diyor hayrola?
Biz satmak istiyoruz böyle bir fikir.
Kaça diyor Altavista. 1 milyon
dolar yeter diyorlar.
1 milyon dolar. Milyar değil milyon.
Burada dört bin kişiysek adam başı 250
dolar eder. 750’şer lira. Alalım Google’ı.
Altavista kendisini batıracak olan bu
projeye bakıyor, kalsın diyor. İyi günler.
Yahoo, Netscape. Netscape hatırlayan?
Yine öğrencilerim hatırlamıyor. Excite?
Hiçbiri Google’ı bu fiyata almıyor,
Google oradan patlıyor.
Peki burada asıl ders ne?
En büyük fırsatı az daha kim kaçırıyor?
Google.
Kendini 1 milyon dolara satmaya çalışarak
en büyük fırsatı aslında Google kaçırıyor.
Bu kahramanlarımız, bu girişimciler,
bu fikri yaratan adamlar.
Google’ı yapan adamlar kendi başarılarını
tahmin edemiyorlar. Korkunç bir şey.
Bunun gibi çok örnek var. Penisilin.
Penisilin milyonlarca insanın
hayatını değiştiriyor.
İlk antibiyotik. Alexander Fleming
istemeden buluyor, kazara.
Net, bir sürü net var.
O netleri birleştiriyorlar,
internet diyelim diyorlar
Bir patlıyor oradan kendimizi
durduramıyoruz bir daha. İyi günler.
Bütün altyapımız şu an
internet üzerinden.
Evinizde kullandığınız bilgisayar. Fareli,
klavyeli, ikonlu, grafik arayüzlü.
İlk kim yapmış onu? Bill Gates değil.
Steve Jobs değil. Apple değil.
Microsoft değil. IBM değil.
Xerox.
Xerox buluyor bunu.
Bakıyor 80’lerin başında bundan bir şey
olmaz, ben fotokopi çekeceğim diyor.
(Gülüşmeler)
O sırada oradan Steve Jobs geçiyor,
o fırsatı değerlendiriyor.
Şu an dünyanın en değerli şirketi Apple.
Peki bana söyler misiniz bundan
sonra ülkeyi, sektörü,
dünyayı değiştirecek olan fikir, fırsat,
teknoloji, altyapı, kitap hangisi?
Ne olur söyleyin.
Zengin olacağız bu arada,
tarihe geçeceğiz. Söyler misiniz?
Çok güzel. Kendi işiniz mi?
Bilmiyoruz, bilmiyoruz.
İşin çok komiği, daha doğrusu
çok korkuncu o her ne ise
üzerinde onun çalışanlar da bilmiyorlar.
Hiçbir fikrimiz yok.
Çünkü bayanlar baylar böyle garip
bir dünyaya dönüştü dünyamız.
Çok karmaşık diyoruz, öngörülemez
diyoruz ama böyle yan etkileri var.
Steve Jobs demiş noktaları geriye
doğru birleştirebiliyoruz.
Diyoruz ki Google tabi çok iyi fikir.
Harry Potter'ı enayiler
nasıl geri çevirmişler.
Ama bir gün öncesinde tahmin etmeye,
bilmeye imkan yok.
Onu yapan da tahmin edemiyor. Tahmin
edebilirmişiz gibi geliyor, bilmiyoruz.
Uzmanlık böyle garip bir şeye dönüştü.
Bunu kuğular üzerinden anlatıyor. Nassim
Taleb diye bir istatistikçi, bir yazar.
Diyor ki bir milyon tane kuğu görün,
hepsi bembeyaz olsun.
Uzmanı olun bir sonraki kuğu beyaz olacak
diyemezsiniz, siyah çıkar. İyi günler.
Kuğu kendisi de şaşırır ne olduğuna.
Siyah kuğu teorisi deniyor buna.
Bunun Natalie Portman’la, baleyle alakası
yok bu arada. O başka siyah kuğu.
Bu da başka. İkisi de güzel.
Böyle bir dünyada başınıza gelebilecek
belki en kötü şey bir ülkenin,
bir şirketin, bir insanın yapabileceği
belki en büyük hata fırsat körlüğü.
Bunları kaçırmak. Ve sürekli sistematik
olarak devamlı kaçırmak.
Nasıl yakalayacağız?
Fırsat nasıl yakalanır?
Bunların ışığında 3 tane strateji önermek
istiyorum sizlere. 3 strateji önereceğim.
İlki “keşke, ah ya, tüh be” dememek.
Ama biz çok seviyoruz bunu.
Geçmişe takılıp kalmayı,
bu lafları çok seviyoruz.
Gerçek hikaye. Bir arkadaşım var,
3-4 senedir her gün kalkıyor
“abi” diyor “bir şey kaçmış,
abi naptık ya, abi ya, Emre ya.”
Yeter be! Kalk, çık, devam. Çünkü
o sırada başka bir sürü fırsat kaçıyor.
Ben bu arada bunalıma
girmeyelim demiyorum.
Hani fırsat kaçınca insan bunalıma girer.
Ama hobi olarak girelim, çıkalım.
3 gün girelim, 5 gün girelim,
ağlayalım sonra çıkalım.
Mücadeleye devam. Önümüze bakmamız lazım.
İlk strateji keşke dememek.
Geçmişe takılıp kalmamak.
Çok hızlı değişiyor dünya. İkinci
strateji çok denemek. Ama çok denemek.
Edison. Takımı beraber altı bin değişik
materyal denemek zorunda kalmışlar
istedikleri ampule ulaşıncaya kadar.
Adamlar beş bin dokuz yüz doksan
dokuz kere başarısız olmuş.
On iki kere reddedilmiş Harry Potter.
Ben on iki kere reddedilmem. Ben iki
kere, üç kere reddedilirim.
Derim benden hiçbir şey olmaz. İyi günler.
Ama öyle değil dünya şu an.
Ne yazık ki bizim eğitim sistemimiz,
iş yapış şeklimiz bunun biraz
gerisinde kalmış durumda.
Başarısızlık mesela bizde yerin dibine
batırılır. Hata yapmak kabul edilemez
Kaybeden hayal kırıklığı.
Biz ne zaman aslında ters mantık
başarısızlıklarımızı başarımızın
üzerine yazmaya başlayacağız öz
geçmişimizde o zaman fırsatları
beklenmedik şekilde yakalamaya
başlayacağız.
Aynı ters mantık şurada da
geçerli, bunun araştırmaları var.
Mesela biz zeki deriz insanlara,
yetenekli deriz.
O zaman ne oluyor, o yetenekli ve zeki
insanlar, zeki ve yetenekli olmama
korkusuyla hata yapmaktan çekinmeye,
denememeye başlıyorlar.
Bu dünyada büyük hata. O zaman fırsatlar
kaçıyor. Bizim tam tersi başarıyı,
azmi, mücadeleyi övmemiz,
ödüllendirmemiz lazım.
İkinci strateji çok denemek,
buna uygun ortamı hazırlamak.
Üçüncü strateji en zoru ve belki kimse
bahsetmediği için aralarında en çok
farkı yaratacak olanı bu kadınla alakalı.
Leslie Winston, kendisi Avustralyalı.
Bir gün iş yerinden evine
dönerken çok feci düşüyor,
dişini kırıyor yapacak bir şey yok.
Bu arada saçmalıyorum şu an.
Kim olduğunu bilmiyorum bu kadının,
adamın altı tane parmağı var.
Var mı ben söylemeden gördüm diyen?
Gördüm diyen var mı?
Zor, çok zor. Adamın kulağı yok.
Var. Yok. Var yok, var yok, var.
Eksiği de görmüyor gözü insanın,
fazlayı da görmüyor.
Çok mantıklı, insanın yüzüne odaklanıyor.
Etrafındaki kaçıyor.
Soru şu; insanın gözü böyle yanılıyorsa,
gözünün önündeki fırsatları da
kaçırıyor olabilir mi?
Bunun üzerine bir deney var.
Richard Wiseman diye bir adam,
İngiliz Psikolog bir deney yapıyor.
Diyor iki tip adam vardır dünyada,
çok böyle garip.
Bir tanesinin fırsatlar ayağına gelir,
devamlı şanslıdır, işleri rast gider.
Ballı deriz biz onlara.
Aramızda var mı ballıyım diyen?
Merhaba, hoşgeldiniz.
Bravo. Bravo. Var mı?
Çok güzel, çok sağ olun, memnun oldum.
Bir de tersi vardır bunun.
Böyle işleri rast gitmez,
girdiği sıra yürümez, hani şanssızdır.
Sıkıntılıdır. Bahtsız deriz.
Bahtsız var mı aramızda?
Sağ olun, memnun oldum.
Memnun oldum, sağ olun.
Bu iki tip insanı alıyor,
bir odaya koyuyor.
Önlerine bir gazete veriyor ve
diyor ki bana lütfen gazetedeki
fotoğrafları sayar mısınız?
Doğru sayarsanız size
adam başı elli lira vereceğim.
Hemen başlıyorlar bir, iki, üç, dört,
beş, altı, yedi, sekiz, dokuz, on saymaya.
Ama işin içinde bir bityeniği var.
İç sayfalardan bir tanesine kocaman bir
ilan koyuyor. Üzerinde hiç fotoğraf yok.
İlanda büyük harflerle şu yazıyor.
Saymayı bırakın, kırk üç tane
fotoğraf var bu gazetede ve eğer bu
ilanı gördüğünüzü bana söylerseniz
size beş yüz lira vereceğim.
Fırsat koyuyor adam içeri
ve bu fırsatı o iki gruptan biri daha
çok görüyor. Hangi grup?
Ballılar. Niye? Çünkü ballı onlar.
Ama bir de ne yazık ki- insanın beyni de
böyle çalışıyor- ne yazık ki gördüğümüzün
etrafını görememek gibi odaklandığımız
yerin etrafını algılamamak gibi
bir durumumuz da var.
Ballılar, burada bahtsızlardan biraz
ayrılıyor. Daha şanslı olmak mümkün yani.
İkisi de böyle başlıyorlar.
Tünele giriyorlar, sayıyorlar.
Bir kere sayıyorlar, iki kere sayıyorlar,
üç kere sayıyorlar, dört kere sayıyorlar
Bahtsızlar devam ediyor saymaya bir daha,
bir daha, bir daha, endişeli bir şekilde.
Bitiriyorlar, elli liralarını
alıp gidiyorlar.
Ballılar, iki kere, üç kere
sayıyorlar, beş kere sayıyorlar
sonra “yeter ya” diyorlar,
o tünelden çıkıyorlar.
Görevlerinin ötesine geçiyorlar biraz.
Gazeteyi okumaya başlıyorlar.
Odaklarını dağıtıyorlar.
O parmağı, o kulağı görüyorlar
ve okumaya başlayınca
-işte burçlar, geçen günün özeti- ve
beş yüz lirayı kazanıyorlar. İyi günler.
Bu şekilde alıyorlar. O kadar karışık
ki dünya, o tünele girince
etrafında kaçan fırsatları görmüyoruz.
Üçüncü strateji o yüzden biraz odağı
dağıtabilmek, farklı yerlerden
beyni besleyebilmek.
Farklı noktaları görüp
onları birleştirebilmek.
Eğitim sistemi -özür dileyerek söylüyorum
yine- ve iş yapma alışkanlığımız
hala biraz geriden geliyor.
Bunu değiştirmeye çalışıyoruz.
Mesela şu an ben ikisinin de
içindeyim, görüyorum.
Evladım sen gel, aman otur,
test test test, yap yap yap.
Dışarı çıkayım, hayır çıkma önüne bak.
Hanımefendi, beyefendi gelin oturun.
Bizim istediğimiz şekilde, bizim
dediğimiz yerde,
bizim istediğimiz işi o şekilde yapın.
Aman dışarı bakmayın. Sosyal medya yasak.
Yok böyle bir dünya şu an,
böyle çalışmıyor.
Ama bu sistemler yavaş değişiyor.
Biz ne yapabiliriz? Soru bu.
Hobi. Hobi bir taktik.
Hobiniz-
Ama hobi şöyle: sizi beklenmedik
problemlerle, beklenmedik insanlarla,
beklenmedik yerlerle tanıştıracak,
içeriden ateşlediğiniz,
böyle severek yaptığınız bir hobi.
Var mı böyle bir hobiniz?
Az el kalkıyor.
Onun da sebebi diğer sistemler aslında.
Diğer sistemler itiyor hobiyi dışarı.
Bir de şöyle kaldıranlar var. Onlar ne?
Hani hobi olarak yapıyorum
mu demek o?
Bizde Türkçe’de öyle. “Hobi olarak
yapıyorum” yapmıyorum demek bizde.
Yazık oluyor. Nasıl yazık oluyor?
Clarice Crosby. 1900’lerin başında
yaşamış Amerikalı bir yazar.
Hobisi dans etmek. Dans etmeyi seviyor.
Ama o sırada herkes korse takıyor,
korseden nefret ediyor. Problemi o.
Bir gün kafasına tak ediyor,
diyor ben buna bir şey yapacağım.
Elinden dikiş nakış falan da geliyor.
İki tane mendil, bir tane şeridi alıyor,
birleştiriyor, onu giyiyor.
İnanılmaz dans ediyor.
Millet etrafına toplanıyor,
nasıl böyle hareket ettin?
Uyanıyor oradan, noktalar birleşiyor,
hani o kimsenin görmediği şeyi görüyor
Sütyen.
1914 yılında patentini alıyor.
İlk modern sütyeni yapıyor.
Burada bir girişim başlatıyor.
1940’larda George de Mestral,
İsviçreli bir mühendis. Boş zamanında
hobisi köpeği ile dağlarda, ovalarda
dolaşmak, trekking yapmak, avlanmak.
En gıcık olduğu şey, döndükten sonra
köpeğinin o tüylerinin arasından
böyle bitkileri, tohumları ayıklamak.
Yav diyor niye böyle yapıyor bu?
Bu yapışkan değil, bu manyetik değil,
nedir bunun işi?
Ben bir gün götüreceğim
bakacağım diyor.
Labaratuvarında mikroskobun altına
koyuyor. ‘Cırt cırt’ buluyor adam.
Cırt cırt. Cırt cırt deyip geçmeyin.
Uzaya gidiyor adam bu fikriyle.
Fırsat böyle çalışıyor.
Nasa'nın en çok kullandığı malzemelerden
bir tanesi cırt cırt şu an.
Her şeyin yerli yerinde durması lazım
yapıştırmadan, manyetik alan kullanmadan.
İki tane doktora öğrencisi, Amerika’da,
90’ların ortasında dijital bir kütüphanede
bilgi ve kitap aramaya yönelik algoritma
yazıyorlar doktora tezleri olarak.
Bir bakıyorlar internet de böyle bir yer.
Aha Google.
Ve de Google gibi şirketler bugün belki
kendilerini tahmin edememenin getirdiği
erdemle çalışanlarına
boşluklar bırakıyorlar.
Diyorlar ki gelin, kaybetme korkusu
olmadan deneyin, icat çıkartın,
uğraşın, kendinizden bir şey katın.
Sonunda çıkan icatlardan bazıları Gmail.
Var mı Gmail’iniz?
Google Talk, AdSense.
Sonunda yine kazanan Google oluyor.
Bütün bu anlattığım hikaye aslında
hani bir anoloji olarak
hayatınızın aşkını bulmaya benziyor biraz.
Hayatının aşkını bulmuş olanlar
şu an beni daha iyi anlayacaklar.
Çünkü bulduğunuz andan sonra
hayatınız nasıl değişti? Buff. İnanılmaz.
Peki bulduğunuz andan önceye gelin.
Tahmin edebildiniz mi ne zaman, nasıl,
nerede karşılaşacağınızı?
İmkan yok, çok zor.
O yüzden bu anlattığım stratejiler
hali hazırda hayatının aşkını
arayanlar için de geçerli.
Ama bir fikir olarak baktığınızda buna,
bir fırsat olarak baktığınızda
şu an aramızdan, bunu izleyenler
arasından dünya çapında, ülke çapında,
sektör çapında, en azından
kişisel bazda hiç beklemediğiniz
korkunç büyük bir fırsat, bir siyah kuğu
çıkmaması için en ufak bir sebep yok.
Yok. Sıfır. Yeter ki ama bunalmayalım.
Bunalıma girip geçmişlerde
takılıp kalmayalım.
Yeter ki başarısız olmak korkusuyla
denemekten vazgeçmeyelim.
Yeter ki odağımızı, dikkatimizi
dağıtıp biraz farklı noktaları,
kimsenin görmediği yerleri
biraz görebilelim.
Bayanlar baylar mücadeleye devam.
Bol şans her koşulda.
Çok teşekkürler. Çok sağ olun.
(Alkışlar)